non mi toccate No no no
Aiuto ma tu non sei Babbo Natale sei Il
il
[Musica]
il in questo video film di Natale nella
vita reale Mamma ho perso l'aereo e il
grin
presto il volo sta per partire Tu
finisci la valigia Io vado a controllare
se i ragazzi sono
pronti devo sbrigarmi prima finisco
prima vado a fare la seconda
colazione non vedo
l'ora m forse no Ah questo è bello però
no
Ah che bello Forse questo me lo porto
però non sono indecisa Uffa non so
proprio quale
scegliere Ok mi sembra di aver messo
tutto quello che mi serve ho messo il
mio cellulare il mio pallone da calcio
tutti i miei videogame il mio Elmo da
gladiatore e anche la mia spada Sì ok
perfetto
cavolo Oh no mi so messo troppa
roba è troppo pesante così farò cadere
l'aereo Ah Dove sono i miei vestiti
Kevin li hai nascosti tu dov'è il mio
cerchietto e le mie scarpe
sbrilluccicose le hai nascoste tu lo so
dove le hai messe non hai prove che sono
stato
io non ti credo sei stato per forza tu
la nostra sorellina luna non può essere
stata è così brava e
carina sei stato per forza tu e se lo
dicessi alla mamma No no ti prego ti
prego mi metterà in punizione a vita se
azzardi a farlo taglio tutti i capelli a
tutte le tue Barbie Oh no le Barbie No
non le toccare allora siete pronti B sta
per
partire avete fatto le valigia siete
tutti pronti Sono quasi pronta Devo solo
scegliere che pupazzo portarmi per il
viaggio No io ancora non sono pronta
perché Kevin ha nascosto No non è vero
no Non è vero Non hai prove Kevin ha
nascosto tut vero Sei la figlia adottata
No tu sei adottato trovato Cetto e a te
nella scarpa di
papà non ci stavo nella scarpa di papà E
invece sì ma basta non c'è tempo
dobbiamo andare il volo sta per partire
andiamo presto sbrigatevi sbrigatevi
andiamo noi iniziamo andare
raggiungeteci subito
Ok Che cosa dici E invece sì lo sai
anche tu papà 68 di piede Ma cosa 68
Sì invece Ecco perché puzzi di piedi
sempre
Boh Oh no ma è tardissimo alita sarà già
fuori andiamo con quel ciuffetto sembri
un pennuto andato a male e tu hai i
capelli color pipì e tu color gabinetto
intasato Smettetela di litigare Dobbiamo
partire presto Anita e vitale ci stanno
aspettando in
macchina dove sono finiti ci hanno
lasciati qui da soli ma no saranno
andati a comprare le ultime cose per il
viaggio è vero non si dimenticherebbe
mai di noi dai C'è mancato poco che
perdessimo il volo Ma per fortuna ci
siamo imbarcati all'ultimo momento sì
Infatti Meno male eppure mi sembra che
manchi qualcosa lo so io cosa manca un
bel cornetto alla crema per fare
colazione no Vitale Pensi sempre a
mangiare mi sembra come se avessimo
dimenticato qualcosa te l'ho detto
abbiamo dimenticato di fare colazione
tutto qui No no sento che manca
qualcos'altro
aspetta Abbiamo dimenticato dei
ragazzi Aspetta ragazzi Il volo partiva
alle 10 giusto Sì perché solo le 10:30
Saranno già partiti E adesso come
facciamo Ci hanno lasciati da soli
Allora possiamo chiamarli con i
cellulari Ottima idea ma dove ho messo
il cellulare li avete messi nelle valige
le valigie le hanno prese
loro
aspetta questo è
perfetto È vero è tutto perfetto anite
Vitale non ci sono e questo vuol dire
casa
libera adesso Posso truccarmi con i
trucchi di Anita Che bello Che bello
adesso posso giocare quanto voglio con i
miei pupatti e guardare i video su
YouTube e anche mangiare tutti i
dolcetti che voglio e io posso giocare
ai videogiochi quanto voglio sì e adesso
andiamo a divertirci e e vai vai
[Musica]
Sì ora che i grandi se ne sono andati è
arrivato il momento giusto per entrare
in quella casa e rubare tutto Ah sì E
quei ragazzini non potranno farci
proprio niente chissà quanta Argenteria
Quante posate piatti i miei amati piatti
Ma perché ti piacciono così tanto i
piatti mi fai diventare piatt fobica Ma
che dici i piatti son bellissimi
d'argento d'oro Oh placcati in titanio
io Io amo i piatti amo i piatti e
saranno tutti i miei Va bene ti lascio i
soldi e Va bene prenditi i piatti tanto
non ce ne facciamo nulla Io vi prendo i
soldi i gioielli le collane gli anelli
tutto quanto Ok Presto sbrighiamoci
prima che tornino gli adulti
andiamo Che bello Sì siamo da soli che
bello però io sento un po' di fame e
dite di prepararci Qualcosa sì dai Anita
mi fai un panino ho fame Sono andati via
Siamo da soli non possono prepararci da
mangiare non ci sono dovremmo cucinarci
qualcosa da soli ma io non so cucinare
come
facciamo io ho un'idea Perché non
cerchiamo da tutte le parti i dolcetti
che nasconde sempre Anita sì i dolcetti
così mangeremo quelli senza che lei ci
dica niente Sì cerchiamolo
ci sono spezie sì che no non ci sono
neanche qui guardiamo qui Li abbiamo
trovati sono
[Musica]
qui che belli Sì sì che bu Li abbiamo
trovati sì
mettiamoli qua Wow che
[Musica]
bello Vai
piano hai fatto un casino Però siamo
riusciti ad entrare e adesso andiamo a
prendere tutto quello che troviamo
[Musica]
sì
Ok ragazzi siamo pronti partenza
via è il miglior pranzo di tutta la mia
vita secondo te a che gusto è questo m
m
noni mangiato così
bene che buono questo m anche
questa
m Questo è veramente buono m anche
questo voglio stare qui per tutta la
vita il miglior pranzo di
sempre Sì è vero ma mi sta venendo un
po' di m di pancia forse non è molto il
caso di mangiare tutti questi dolci Però
sono così
buoni questo è
[Musica]
buonissimo davvero Ragazzi ho sentito un
rumore un po' strano mi sa È meglio che
G vada a controllare Noi mangiamo lo
stesso inf
Ah e voi due Chi
siete Cosa ci fate qui in casa nostra E
noi siamo noi siamo qui per la
disinfestazione Sì Esatto esatto ciè
stato detto che avete un problema di
insetti e noi siamo qui per sistemarlo
Esatto Sì sì sì che cosa sta succedendo
Che cosa sono queste voci Non lo so
Andiamo a controllare
un po' di paura andiamo di festazione e
quindi voi fate le feste io non ho
chiamato nessun festaiolo non siete i
benvenuti a casa nostra feste Sì sì sì
questo le feste Sì sì le feste Sì sì
facciamo le feste facciamo le feste
siamo venuti a fare una festa qui ci
hanno chiamato i vostri genitori A
proposito dove sono che ci devono dare
direttive Sì esatto ma che festa è
sembrate vistiti da latri latri Cè scopo
SC è solo un ragazo
prendiamolo non mi toccate No no no
Aiuto no Ma quelli sono dobbiamo aiutare
Kevin
aiuto
[Musica]
pri tornate più Sì azzardatevi esatto
Altrimenti ve la vedrete con noi
giusto Questi ragazzi sono pestiferi Sì
ma non possiamo dar la vinta dobbiamo
trovare un altro modo per entrare e
sconfiggere quei tre ragazzini stupidi
Ehi Ragazze venite qui sicuramente i
ladri torneranno è vero torneranno
dobbiamo preparare delle trappole per
quando lo faranno Sì buona idea così li
spaventerai Appo in ogni entrata Sì
buona idea Ok perfetto Mettiamoci a
lavoro ora andiamo Esatto andiamo
Dobbiamo trovare un nuovo piano per
entrare nella casa Allora fammi pensare
ce l'ho ce l'ho ce l'ho ce l'ho Ce l'ho
eh gli facciamo la cacca nel bagno così
con l'odore la puzza loro entreranno in
bagno a vedere cosa è successo noi gli
chiudiamo gli chiudiamo e abbiamo tutta
la casa libera perfetto che idea stupida
forse se ti tiro un colpo ti Ahia ahia
ho preso pensa qualcos'altro ok pensiamo
un altro ci caliamo Dai camini ma Mina
sei Babbo Natale Ho un'idea io Potremmo
entrare dalla finestra in modo tale che
non ci vedranno mai giusto entriamo
dalla finestra e poi andiamo in bagno a
fare la cacca No niente cacca in questo
piano ma io devo fare la cacca mi scappa
vai in quel cespuglio Oh il cespuglio
sempre nel cespuglio Sì però veloce che
dobbiamo andare dai dai dai Su su vai
vai
vai Eccoli li vedo si stanno avvicinando
tutti a posti di partenza correte Sì
Sì eccoli lì Ok perfetto tiate al
momento giusto Mi raccomando Sarà
proprio un gioco da ragazzi entrare in
questa casa e rubare tutto come bere un
bicchi d'acqua infatti però non
dimentichiamoci di andare in bagno Oh ma
che cosa stai dicendo andare in bagno
ancora ce l'hai con questa cacca Sì devo
andare va bene sbrighiamoci
Vai
una aiuto
ai Ok
pronta tir male non
sono Cosa sono
questi Oh vieni vieni
scappa che
schifo
Vediti tu quello che vedo io sì quello è
un forziere presto
vieni abbiamo forse trovato i tesori di
questa
casa attento potrebbe esserci qualche
trappola Ah sto
scherzando
Uh vediamo un po' è bellissimo uh uh ci
dobo lasciare le monete d'oro qui dentro
[Musica]
Ah che schifo Come'è
Spero gli piacciano le scariche
[Musica]
elettriche Ehi stanno arrivando è l'ora
di fare il prossimo
scherzetto basta con questi scherzi di
questi ragazzini stupidi ragazzini Sono
traumatizzata Oh va bene Adesso adesso
concentriamoci a rubare ok Sì
[Musica]
andiamo no Ah
aiuto e adesso lo scherzo finale andiamo
andiamo andiamo forza
andiamo basta basta con questi scherzi
di questi ragazzini non ce la faccio
più Ora basta niente ci fermerà più sì
andiamo subito a rubare tutto
Infatti non c'è nulla ma dove sono le
monete d'oro qui le gemme
preziose ho trovato io qualcosa anche io
oh questo è bello questo lo rubiamo Sì
ok
[Musica]
Eh adesso vi mangio come la
nonna vi mangio vi digerisco e vi
trasformo in
Slime volete giocare con
me
ce ne andiamo ce ne andiamo guard dietro
Apri
scappa C son proprio cascati
[Musica]
Esatto Missione compiuta Sì siamo stati
bravissimi
sì sì ce l'abbiamo fatta sì ragazzi
Eccoci qua C'eravamo dimenticati qu
Eccoci qua che cosa avete fatto mentre
non c'eravamo abbiamo fatto spaventare e
allontanare dei ladri che stavano
entrando qui in casa Certo che questi
bambini hanno proprio tanta
fantasia un rumore La notte di Natale
devo essere sicuramente Babbo Natale
vado subito a
conoscerlo
[Musica]
Non vedo l'ora di conoscere babbo natale
chissà che regali mi
[Musica]
porterà il
Natale questo per
me questo invece per Aspetta che ci
penso un attimo per
me per me anche questo e poi e poi e poi
questo Oh ma questo è fantastico anche
questo per me e adesso bruo anche
l'albero il Natale non vincerà mai
contro di
me
[Musica]
Ehi babbo natale Sei qui per portarmi i
regali Ma tu non sei Babbo Natale sei il
Il il
il e non sono qui per portarti i regali
ma per
rubarli e adesso bambina vai subito a
dormire oppure questi li brucio
tutti
aiuto adoro spaventare le
ragazine e adesso con tutti questi
regali posso finalmente andare a casa e
scartarli
tutti
Guardate lì Il Grinch Dove dove ma non
c'è
C Ma Ma aiuto i dove i regali dove sono
finiti sono
spariti i regali sono spariti siete
stati voi ve l'ho detto è stato Il
Grinch ma Il Grinch è solo una leggenda
vero Sì sì forse eri sonnambula hai
fatto un brutto sogno io lo so cosa ho
visto era Il Grinch verde e antipatico
però i regali sono spariti quindi uno di
voi li ha fatti sparire No non siamo
stati noi E chi ci dice che non sei
stata tu esatto e ci vuoi incolpare solo
perché sei stata tu a nasconderli Ma no
non farei mai sparire i vostri regali e
perché dovremmo farlo noi Esatto Beh
sicuramente i regali Sono qua in giro
per casa quindi l'unica cosa che ci
resta da fare è dividerci e cercarli Io
inizio a controllare qua vediamo se
trovo qualche regalo e voi andate nelle
altre stanze a controllare Ok io vado di
là io là ok Ehi Ma a proposito Voi avete
cliccato mi piace cliccate subito mi
piace qua sotto e l'ultima cifra del
vostro mi piace corrisponde a uno dei
personaggi di Natale quale personaggio
vi è
capitato scrivetelo nei commenti e ora
continuiamo la nostra ricerca dei regali
mi sembra molto strano che i regali sono
spariti Chi sarà
stato dove saranno Ehi Merlino eh
gattine voi sapete per caso dove sono i
regali
Chissà chi li ha nascosti insomma Chi è
così cattivo da nascondere i regali il
giorno di Natale sono anche i
suoi noi non abbiamo trovato niente È
inutile Ve l'ho già detto è stato Il
Grinch sto cominciando a crederci
anch'io Ma davvero credete al Grinch
Insomma come fate a credere a queste
cose è così stupido è una leggenda che
si raccontava ai bambini Beh io
incominciando a credere a Cindy insomma
chi può essere d' aver nascosto i regali
di Natale è così bello scartarli tra di
noi non è possibile neanche Anita quindi
per forza è stato Il Grinch può essere
stato anche un lagro sì il lagro E
secondo te non l'avremmo sentito basta
l'ho visto con i miei occhi è Il Grinch
l'ho visto se non mi credete soltanto
perché sono una
bambina mi sembra di vedere qualcosa
dietro a questa
tenda qualcuno si nasconde qua dietro
proviamo ad aprire la
[Applauso]
tenda
Anita andiamo Dobbiamo
salvarla è
qua cosa è
[Applauso]
successo
verde molto verde ed è incredibilmente
peloso ve l'avevo detto dovete credere
ai bambini presto dobbiamo unire le
nostre forze per scacciare via il grin
Ok Uniamo le nostre forze forse possiamo
riuscire a sconfiggerlo Ottima idea
Vai Fermi Fermi state fermi lì voi non
sapete che cosa posso farvi io i GD
fermi lì non azzardatevi a prendermi io
posso distruggere tutti i natali per
sempre
prendiamolo vi via Vieni qua
Vai
aiuto
nonii oltre a essere peloso pesa
purei
1 2 3
[Musica]
Sì abbiamo scitto il
gr e abbiamo recuperato anche tutti i
regali
[Applauso]
Sì buone beste a
tutti
Ciao